[Music]
we've got kyle in philadelphia
pennsylvania kyle welcome to the ramsay
show
hey guys how's it going great how can we
help
um yeah so i actually just had a
question of i'm fairly new to the whole
uh
that snowball method and everything like
that welcome to the crazy gang brother
yeah i know right
um so i kind of just had a question of
how i should get started um i guess a
little back story is i
recently just purchased a
new car uh well fairly new car
2017 mazda back in january of 2020
uh right before everything happened of
course but uh so i was actually living
with parents my rent was like 250.
um but
then i got kicked out
so uh why'd they kick you out
uh just bad relationship with stepmom
kyle
nothing to do
what did you do you're on the radio
you're not allowed to tell us
it was just arguments all the time i
wasn't the nicest person
um
so now that i'm paying rent um honestly
the second biggest expense i have is my
car
um and i'm in a unique situation where
my car
is valued at what i owe
the problem is
is i've been doing the death snowball so
i don't have any leftover money i'm on
baby step two so i already have my
emergency fund everything else i had i
dumped into debt so i'm trying to figure
out how to like if i should sell my car
and then
um
like pretty much save up money
to be able to buy a new car then sell my
car or like that's why i'm calling you
guys i'm kind of just trying to figure
out my situation best route for me what
do you owe uh so i owe 12.5 and my car
value is
is higher than 12.5 but i have uh i was
involved in a hit and run so
with the damage my car is valued at 12.5
okay and is that your only debt
no i have credit card debt uh pretty
much everything together five out
uh i got maybe like
just under five grand of credit card
debt
okay and what do you mean
uh so i make about no i'm bad at math i
would say maybe
38 000
maybe 39. you can be really bad at math
but you know your salary
yeah true
um so i think what do you do for a
living 39.
i work in a financial institution you're
a financial advisor and you don't know
how much money you make he never said he
was an advisor what do you do i wasn't
an advisor i'm a banker ah see the
opposite side you're a banker that
doesn't know how much money he makes
you are you are
you're reinstilling confidence in
america don't name the bank i don't know
that people are going to want to go
there
okay well let's help kyle out let's help
let's help this guy out so you've got a
thousand dollar emergency fund and
you're saying if i can sell the car i'll
be kind of at zero with the car i'll
zero out that debt i'll still have 5 000
in credit card debt right
correct okay and you then you still need
a car
exactly i still need a car that's my
problem yeah how quickly could you save
up
four thousand dollars three thousand
dollars to go get a cheap car
yeah that's and that's the second
biggest issue is i saw i just said i
make like twenty four hundred dollars a
month uh i have about two grand with the
bills um
so how are the bills two grand
just everything all together i mean i'm
talking i'm also explaining like
i put in my gas my grocery store
your total expenses are two grand
yeah everything every month
two grand
okay and you're saying you have 400 left
to throw at the debt snowball
pretty much uh sometimes a little less
if i you know work less hours or
anything like that but can you can you
work
more hours can you pick up side jobs
so the problem is my fan it's really
weird but the bank i work at doesn't
allow us to have a second job i don't
know why but kyle that's not even a kyle
that's not even a thing i've never heard
of that i can't tell you what you can do
off hours you can go drive uber you can
go work at starbucks or mcdonald's
mcdonald's is paying like 111 an hour
now because there's no workers they're
desperate you can go stock shelves at a
grocery store
and you're making they said it's like
against like you're making 38 000 a year
you're not making a million and so if
they're gonna cap you at under 40 grand
a year and not let you get other work
you need to go find another job
today
here's what i'm hearing i'm hearing a
dude who is pretty smart
who's got an attitude problem and who
thinks he's got stuff figured out and he
wants to change stuff but not really am
i fair
yeah yeah
but here's what we do on this show we
love you and we tell the truth to you
okay
is that cool
that works here's
brother you're a banker you're smart i
know you are and you're a hustler are
you a hustler
yes i believe i am i agree with you okay
so by the time this weekend is over that
car is sold and you've bought a thousand
dollar hunk of junk that's going to get
you to and fro and no one's going to
want to date you you're not going to
want to be seen and i don't care because
you're broke you're a broke banker my
brother right yes i am
and you're gonna write your mom your
stepmom a letter and say i'm sorry for
being a jerk and i'm working on it and
then you're gonna get a second and a
third job and you're not gonna go inside
of a restaurant you're not gonna go to a
movie you're not gonna go on a date
you're gonna get this crap paid off asap
and that's the kind of intensity and
that's the kind of swagger you're gonna
have to have to get this stuff knocked
out and you're gonna have to say never
ever again kyle how old are you
25
what do you want to be doing at 30 what
kind of life do you want to have
i want to be debt-free definitely
no that's that's my main problem that's
like that's like six months from now
what do you want to do in five years
um
that's a question i still haven't
figured out yet
i kind of want to be a teacher i'll be
honest with you but then and i go with
student loan debt that's my big problem
there too you don't have to do it you
already capping yourself brother you're
like hey i really want to do this thing
but i can't
i've already got a car but i just i'm
hearing a lot of well my situation is
unique and what you got to understand is
and i'm hearing a lot of excuses you're
not a snowflake kyle go get it brother
i think you need you need to get some
mojo and you need to go get the second
and third job you need to clean up your
life you need to follow the baby steps
get rid of the credit card debt sell the
car get as much money as you can for it
go to you know vroom and carvana and
carmax and every site on the planet to
see if you can maybe make some money off
this thing to then pay for that car in
cash and then go to night school and
take a couple of classes a semester
towards your dream of becoming a teacher
which is an extraordinary profession my
whole family is made up of teachers and
be a part of changing the next
generation of folks they don't have to
live the life that you're living right
now